...E andare incontro al futuro,
con la determinazione non soltanto
di credere alle nuove idee,
quanto di fuggire dalle vecchie!
TEDxBologna: Passione e Creatività 13 ottobre 2012
Oggi vi voglio raccontare una storia futura.
Una storia di una trasformazione sociale,
che io penso avverrà rapidamente.
Rapidamente, in relazione alle scale che vediamo.
E che ci permette di analizzare
e di capire come affrontare questo cambiamento
che sarà appunto secondo me molto rapido.
Questa storia futura
io la analizzo e cerco di capirla
raccontandola a me stesso per primo
e poi raccontandola a voi
perché la vivremo insieme
in un futuro che andremo a costruire.
E parto proprio dalla mia esperienza personale.
Perché ogni storia che ci raccontiamo non può che partire
da quella che viviamo contemporaneamente.
Questa trasformazione della nostra società
da quella che è attualmente a quella che sarà in futuro
io la chiamo la Network Society.
E sono partito nel cercare di capire
come sarà la forma del futuro,
proprio parlando con i miei figli,
che così come me, così come i vostri figli,
vivranno e costruiranno questo futuro.
Loro mi chiedono quali sono le prospettive che potranno vivere,
chiedono quali sono le ambizioni, le opportunità
che il mondo offrirà a loro.
E siccome
io insegno, analizzo, costruisco fenomeni esponenziali.
—fenomeni che partono lentamente
per poi arrivare alla coscienza comune,
arrivare di fronte a tutti noi,
improvvisamente se non siamo attenti
a quello che succede attorno—
ho ben presente quanto sia complesso
e quanto sia difficile
capire i segnali deboli di un futuro
che si avvicina.
La maniera quindi con cui vado ad analizzare il futuro
è una maniera diversa da quella
che vediamo raccontata dai giornali
o che vediamo raccontata dalle televisioni.
È una maniera nuova, che spero anche voi condividerete.
La società attorno a noi
cambia apparentemente lentamente.
Questi cambiamenti sono avvenuti in passato,
in epoche che abbiamo deciso di chiamare in una certa maniera.
L'epoca dei faraoni,
quando venivano costruite le piramidi,
e le epoche successive.
L'epoca dei faraoni,
quando gli schiavi venivano presi a decine di migliaia
perché anno dopo anno costruissero
monumenti meravigliosi
che ancora adesso ammiriamo,
è un'epoca che è finita,
non perché questi schiavi si sono guardati in faccia
e hanno detto "Questo non è giusto, vogliamo ribellarci!"
È un'epoca che è finita per ragioni diverse.
Il medioevo,
che è caratterizzato da una gerarchia feudale,
di rapporti di vassallaggio
e di imperio,
è un'epoca che è finita
non perché sono finiti
i cavalieri medievali che dovessero dominare
i vassalli.
Non è finita perché si è andato a decidere
a priori quale doveva essere il nuovo contratto sociale
o perché la rivoluzione francese
ha risvegliato le coscienze di tutti.
E oggi viviamo in un'epoca industriale
dove molti
vanno a vedere sfide particolari
difficoltà di continua crescita produttiva
o di sfruttamento delle risorse naturali.
Un'epoca industriale che sta trasformandosi
a fatica in un'epoca
che vuole chiamarsi post-industriale
e che si confronta con rivoluzioni culturali,
rivoluzioni demografiche e democratiche.
Ma anche questa non finirà
per un risveglio di coscienza
a trasformarsi in una nuova società,
qualunque sia questa,
e in un qualunque momento questo avvenga.
Sia nelle trasformazioni precedenti,
che in quella che vedremo in futuro,
la chiave è stata una chiave tecnologica.
È quella che precede il cambiamento,
quello che rende possibile il cambiamento.
Le persone, gli individui, i gruppi,
coloro che sognano il cambiamento
certamente si rendono conto
dell'ingiustizia.
Che gli schiavi fossero scontenti
era chiaro nella società egiziana.
Che i vassalli potessero tentare
di fare meglio
è chiaramente raccontato
nelle favole
dove il figlio più piccolo della famiglia
se ne va e alla fine sposa la principessa.
È una concreta rappresentazione
delle ambizioni inespresse
e inesprimibili di quella società.
Ma finché
non è stata scoperta
la forza del vapore
gli idrocarburi
o l'energia atomica sui cui in parte si basa
la nostra società di oggi, non è stato possibile costruire
una forma di società che permettesse
a quelle ambizioni individuali,
culturali, o di un nuovo contratto sociale
di realizzarsi.
Cosa succederà quindi
tra poco? Quali sono
le chiavi di lettura
del futuro,
quali sono i pilastri
che sosterranno il cambiamento che sta arrivando?
Intanto ve ne accenno
e vi do una lettura iniziale
per poi darvi alcuni stimoli,
alcune provocazioni
perché possiate ragionarci su,
se vi fa piacere,
e se condividete questa analisi,
oppure di ribattere che no, non sarà così.
E ce ne saranno altre naturalmente,
ma intanto io vi voglio elencare quattro pilastri di questo cambiamento.
Ognuno di questi quattro pilastri che vi elencherò
hanno la stessa caratteristica.
Ed è per questo che ho dato il nome di Network Society
a quella che verrà tra poco.
Perché opposto a quello che vediamo oggi,
che è una gerarchia centralizzata,
ognuno di questi elementi
è caratterizzato da una distribuzione decentralizzata
ed è questo che produce quest'effetto di rete
che vedremo attorno a noi.
Vediamo per primo quindi la produzione, distribuzione
e utilizzo di energia.
Oggi l'energia che utilizziamo
nasce dagli idrocarburi per la maggior parte,
e un po' dall'atomo.
Ma ci sono già oggi proiezioni che vedono l'energia solare
entro il 2030, quindi poco più di 10 anni da oggi,
15 anni, 18 anni da oggi,
soddisfare al 100%
le necessità di energia della società,
non ai consumi di oggi, ai consumi cresciuti proiettati di allora.
L'energia solare,
la cui efficienza aumenta
alla stessa maniera esponenziale
che abbiamo visto realizzarsi negli ultimi
40-50 anni con l'informatica,
è una modalità distribuita
di produzione dell'energia.
Non c'è bisogno, anche se ci sono progetti che lo prevedono,
fare centrali enormi che producano il fabbisogno
di un'intera regione
o di un'intera nazione o addirittura
di un intero continente.
Quando vedete raccontare che copriremo il Sahara di pannelli solari
per poi portare attraverso superconduttori transoceanici
attraverso il Mediterraneo
in Europa tutta l'energia che serve,
non solo questo progetto sarebbe complicato
e molto fragile, ma assolutamente non necessario,
perché, come sappiamo,
si può mettere pannelli solari sulle case di tutti
si può mettere pannelli solari in campagna, tranquillamente distribuiti.
E ci sono paesi che già lo stanno facendo in modo massiccio
come per esempio la Germania.
Vediamo il secondo pilastro,
la produzione di cibo.
Oggi parliamo di industria agricola, di "agribusiness".
Un modo centralizzato di produrre cereali
di produrre vegetali, di produrre anche carne
in modo appunto industrializzato
dove abbiamo bisogno di standardizzare,
ibridare e di seminare per raccogliere
quantità enormi di cibo uniformato
che poi deve essere trasportato su grandissime distanze.
Opposto a questo
ci sono già delle modalità di crescita di vegetali
in una maniera distribuita
che riproducono un po' quello che è il concetto dell'orto,
controllabile, non solo in campagna, ma anche in ambiente urbano,
all'interno di container da trasporto.
Questi container, utilizzando lampade LED e lampade ad infrarossi,
permettono in coltivazione idroponica
quindi utilizzando pochissima acqua e pochissimo terreno
di dare una resa molto superiore a quello che si può ottenere adesso
in assenza di pesticidi e in assenza di interventi radicali
di ibridazione o di modificazione genetica
che altrimenti nell'industria agricola tradizionale sono necessari.
La cosa più importante di questo approccio
è che trasforma l'agricoltura da una produzione
proporzionale all'area coperta,
ad una proporzionale al volume utilizzato.
E quindi non è più questione
che non ho abbastanza terreno o che
oppure che dobbiamo lasciare terreni incolti
perché questi possano riguadagnare la fertilità
che avevano perso attraverso lo sfruttamento industriale
Ma in ogni città possiamo prendere un edificio alto dieci piani
e due piani di questo dedicarli alla crescita del cibo
consumato all'interno dell'edificio stesso.
Oppure di avere una casa
dove semplicemente sottoterra
si fa crescere il cibo necessario.
Il terzo pilastro è quello della produzione degli oggetti fisici,
tradizionalmente chiamata la produzione industriale.
Anche questa oggi
è centralizzata, addirittura su scala planetaria.
Probabilmente il 70%-80% degli oggetti tecnologici
che abbiamo qua è stato prodotto in Cina
e attraverso una complicatissima
catena di distribuzione, realizzata e trasportata in tutto il mondo
incluso questo luogo,
perché poi venisse acquistato e utilizzato.
La nuova tecnologia della stampa 3D
che permette di realizzare oggetti localmente,
dove la complessità del design
è il valore aggiunto,
ma la complessità della realizzazione
è assolutamente indipendente dalla scala,
Costa uguale stampare un cubo di materiale stupido
quanto stampare un oggetto bellissimo,
complicatissimo e utilissimo.
E oggi siamo sicuramente agli inizi,
ma ci sono stampanti
sempre più sofisticate
che permettono di realizzare
insieme a materiale di supporto circuiti elettrici,
addirittura materiale biologico,
e andremo ad avere
un'infrastruttura distribuita
invece che centralizzata di produzione
che appunto costituisce il terzo pilastro
di questa visione della Network Society.
Il quarto e ultimo
è quello della finanza
che è essa stessa tecnologia.
Quando è stata inventata la moneta come unità di scambio
o unità di immagazzinamento di valore,
è stato un grosso salto tecnologico in avanti.
Ha permesso un miglioramento della qualità della vita umana.
Quello che vediamo oggi
che sono le vicissitudini finanziarie
dovute alla complessità dei derivati
o alla mancanza di regolamento per certuni,
all'eccessivo regolamento per certi altri,
del comportamento delle banche
o delle autorità monetarie centrali,
non può trovare risposta
in un ritorno al passato
abbandonando tutto quello che abbiamo finora costruito.
Così come la risposta ai problemi industriali
non può essere quella di abbandonare le tecnologie
che abbiamo scoperto.
Il passaggio da una gestione centralizzata della finanza
ad una gestione distribuita della finanza
che non è più dipendente da decisioni
che si presuppone autonome
e indipendenti, ma molto spesso politicamente influenzate
e strumentali,
può trovare risposta nell'innovazione matematica
tecnologica, appunto applicata alla finanza.
Uno degli esempi della quale è Bitcoin.
Bitcoin è un tipo di moneta elettronica
anonima, sicura e non tracciabile,
la cui produzione non è in mano ad un'autorità centrale
ma è distribuita.
Così come i protocolli di scambio di file moderni
Non sono dipendenti da server centrali
spegnendo i quali si ferma lo scambio
e permettono legalmente o illegalmente
di scambiare dati,
così l'infrastruttura di Bitcoin
non è dipendente da un server centrale
e permette ad individui o a gruppi di individui
di operare autonomamente
per effettuare quegli scambi di cui hanno bisogno.
Abbiamo visto quindi quattro pilastri
e vi invito naturalmente di verificare quello che ho detto
di approfondire perché vediate con i vostri occhi
la potenza letteralmente rivoluzionaria
di queste tecnologie fondamentali
che porteranno al cambiamento societario che vi ho descritto
e quindi di chiedervi così come sto facendo io
quale sarà la forma di questo futuro,
quale sarà la forma della Network Society
dove il carburante delle automobili elettriche
non è più prodotta centralmente
ma è prodotta individualmente.
Come sarà tassata questa cosa
se lo Stato ha bisogno di produrre il 60% del costo del carburante in tasse
È quello il prodotto del vostro trasporto.
Come sarà la forma del futuro
nel momento in cui
la finanza non è più controllata centralmente
quando gli individui potranno
in base alla reciproca fiducia
che hanno o non hanno in uno o nell'altro
concedere mutui, concedere prestiti
e non ci sarà più la banca che decide
che cosa debba succedere, chi può averlo o chi non può averlo.
Che cosa succederà alle industrie alimentari attuali
quando la produzione di cibo potrà essere
delocalizzata, potrà essere distribuita
potrà essere rivoluzionata in base ai principi che vi ho descritto.
Io ritengo che sarà un cambiamento radicale
un cambiamento rivoluzionario verso appunto la Network Society,
che voi e io insieme ai miei figli vivremo.
Vi ringrazio.